Public Health embraced this idea of a
noble lie right if I I'll lie to you
about the efficacy of mass
why because otherwise you won't wear
them I'll lie to you about whether the
vaccine stopped transmission why because
you might then otherwise not get the
vaccine yeah yeah those lies undermine
Trust
hello and welcome to Marshall matches
with me Winston Marshall at The
Spectator in London I explore
taboo topics and speak to heterodox
thinkers and as well as exploring Free
Speech issues and my guest today is one
of the most censored men in the west I
believe it's Dr J bhattacharya welcome
Dr vacharya thank you for having me
appreciate it um so uh as well as being
uh well you're a professor at Stanford
University Medical School uh physician
epidemiologist Health Economist Public
Health policy expert focusing on
infectious diseases and vulnerable
populations but famously one of the
co-authors of the Great Barrington
declaration in October 2020 which as we
know well we sort of knew already but as
was confirmed by Barry Weiss and the
Twitter files
was censored by Twitter and we believe
other uh big tech companies uh you've
you've experienced censorship from
YouTube uh and
um I learn also that you've been
censored for by reading your latest
tablet magazine article uh you've
experienced censorship at Stanford
University where you teach and work all
of which I look forward to getting into
with you
um uh and also Keen to talk about your
experience going into Twitter post
elon's takeover and and that experience
but I think we should perhaps start with
uh your uh let's the work that is so
controversial which which is not only
the Great Barrington declaration but the
zero prevalent study of April 2020 which
also got you in uh in trouble so maybe
you can you can explain to our listeners
uh what you set out in those in those
two uh sure things so in uh when the
when the pandemic hit uh you know I've
been writing about uh about infectious
disease and infectious policy for two
decades
uh I I remembered what happened in 2009
during this wine for epidemic that there
was a uh in the early days of the
pandemic the World Health Organization
said that that the death rate was like
very very high
um in 2009 from the swine fluence and uh
uh what happened was that there was a
whole series of studies that was done uh
where people would measure antibodies in
the population at large the antibodies
what they tell you is that is that uh
look you've had the disease and
recovered your body reacts to it
um and and produces antibodies so what
you do is you just go in the population
you say okay how many people out of the
people I sample have antibodies
um Turned out for H1N1 the flu they you
know the swine flu
a hundred times more people had been
infected Than People re than that that
had shown up as cases
because it was for most people was
relatively mild
then it just was a cult so they didn't
go to the doctor doctors didn't know
about it public health didn't know about
it
um and that meant the death rate was
really low
and but it took a long time before the
studies were done initially there was a
big panic over this swine flu so I ran a
study in the early days of the pandemic
uh uh for covet I thought okay well what
if this is very infectious disease what
if the same thing is true that many many
people have had it we just didn't know
about it
uh so in in Santa Clara County
California where I live in L.A County uh
I ran I helped I was a senior author in
in
um these kinds of studies
um what we found was it wasn't like a
lot of the population was about like
three or four percent of the population
in April of 2020 had already had the
disease that sounds like a small number
but that was really controversial like
for a couple of reasons like one is that
it meant that the death rate from the
disease was something like 0.2 percent
99.8 survival the World Health
Organization had been saying three
percent death rates
uh the the so I mean that that's a big
difference like uh I mean and the other
thing was like there was this big age
gradient older people were much much
more likely to die from it than younger
people that was clear even before our
study
um the other the last really
controversial thing about that study uh
the results of the study was that you
know three percent doesn't sound like a
lot but April of 20 early April 2020 the
disease had only been in the country for
not a month month and a half and already
three percent
um
there was no way to stop it right that
meant that the population was going was
going to be infected uh that that and
the only question was who do you protect
in the meantime as the disease spreads
so how why was that so controversial
controversial then if you're a scientist
you're studying these things it's it's
literally your job why would that be
offensive to anyone and what were the
professional repercussions
well I mean it was it was actually quite
painful so um uh the the uh it was a big
media hit I mean like people probably
won't remember now but like back back in
April 2020 it felt like the central
media story
a huge number of of uh of media Outlets
paid attention to it uh it was
controversial because it it's meant that
public health was already doing the
wrong thing
that the lockdowns that we started in
March of 2020 had not worked despite
them three or four percent of the
population already had been infected
right that's you know two three weeks
after the lockdown that's a bad result
um the idea that public health had was
that everyone needed to comply
and partly they used fear-mongering to
do it to over overstate the true death
rate
to get people to be scared of the Z so
they can apply with the lockdown orders
I mean I think that was part of some
people's minds anyways
um and we're coming around saying 0.2
percent
well that's you know point two percent
is not zero I'd rather be zero but it's
it's not as scary as three percent yeah
has the point two percent is that now
has that been approved uh uh still to is
that still yeah I mean there's now
dozens of zero prevalent studies
um in some places like New York where
there's older population there was they
found higher death rates in other places
like in Africa they found lower death
rates was younger
um that point two percent is like
roughly the median estimate so like you
know most of the studies find something
something very very close to that right
so at so with the repercussions at
Stanford or what what exactly happened
when you put out the the Civil
prevalence so when I started getting
attacked by by the Press like there was
this BuzzFeed author that wrote a story
attacking my wife because she'd like
written an email to try to help people
know about this I mean she didn't want
my permission but like she was had meant
had good intentions and she created a
some Scandal out of that uh the the
founder of JetBlue gave that five
thousand dollars to Stanford for the
study
and somehow she turned it into this like
some conflict of interest as if I'm
going to change the results of the study
the BuzzFeed yeah the BuzzFeed
journalist Stanford then opened it like
what they initially called an
investigation then they turned it into
like a fact-finding mission as soon as
they found we've done nothing wrong
of me it was tremendously stressful I
mean you know like I've never had
anything like that happen to me before
I've been publishing dozen you know I
published 150 studies or whatever in my
career
um I'm a professor in good standing it
was really it was very very stressful
friends of mine turned on Me on the base
of that study really yeah and why do you
think that why do you think that they
turned on you what was so offensive
about it I mean I think they just they
they very strongly believed that it was
a very high mortality disease that that
we'd clearly done something wrong and
they
for whatever reason decided I was a bad
guy for having done the study okay so
fast forward a few months uh to October
and you publish a one sheet the Great
Barrington declaration arguing against
lockdown policy and what happened what
happened then
so that why that the reason we wrote The
Great Barrington necklace the great
Branch Recreation is a very simple idea
um you know there's there's this as I
said there's a thousand four different
older people a much higher risk of
disease of dying if they get the disease
um same time the lockdown strategy we've
adopted have been tremendously harmful
to poor people to Children Working Class
People uh you know closing schools for
instance there was April 2020 or April
May 2020 study by very very well known
pediatrician
um yeah when you close schools down for
a short time you think that okay it's
not such a big deal but in fact it is a
big deal uh especially poor kids who
don't can't get replacement but even
even anyone everyone every kid uh you
you deprive them of learning and that
has lifelong implications like there's a
big literature in in in uh in education
policy and health policy that documents
how important it is for kids to go to
school like full time in person all the
time when when you they don't go to
school they end up living they end up
being poorer they end up living shorter
less healthy lives so the estimate was
we robbed in the United States just from
the spring closures five and a half
million life years from children that
was that was like published paper in
like you know spring of 2020. who
published that paper uh the Journal of
the uh Journal of uh of the American
Medical Association Pediatrics I think
it's this guy named Dimitri kastakas is
a very famous
very well-known pediatrician um uh it
was actually the editor of that journal
um and and then for for uh you know the
UN world food program was saying things
like the the economic harm from the
lockdowns are going to cause
tens of millions of people to to go into
dire poverty worldwide you know you say
supply chain disruptions the pointy end
of that is somebody who's making you
know ten dollars a day of income or uh
in in Uganda or something they're out
they're throwing out of their job
because the supply chain that which
they're at the bottom breaks and now
they're starving
um and so like they're like they're
yelling as far as they can there's gonna
be starvation from these lockdowns
um all these like people are skipping
their their cancer exams you know so so
like so women are going to show up with
late stage breast cancer that should
have been cured so so the great band
technology said look you shouldn't do
these lockdowns they're going to cause
more harm than good
um especially for people who are low
risk
so you have a you have a identified
high-risk population older people you
have this harmful policy that's
devastating poor children working-class
people
um and uh the obvious strategy is
protect vulnerable older people like
move Heaven and Earth to protect them
and we have some a lot of ideas that we
gave in the in the proposal in the great
pension declaration itself and the
accompanying material but we also wanted
to invite Public Health to in to enter
that conversation I mean they know how
the local living circumstances of the
elderly in their Community are they
would have a better idea than us how to
protect them right um and then for the
rest of the population lift the
lockdowns yeah so what was the reception
then because in this country the
co-authors uh sunitra Gupta am I
pronouncing that correctly and Martin
cooldhoff uh I believe were brought to
Downing Street and had a reception with
the prime minister at the time or if not
the Prime Minister someone yeah so
Sinatra actually she went to number 10
actually just just before for the great
branch and declaration right okay yeah
so she uh discussed
so would the Declaration happen because
Martin koldorf was a professor at
Harvard uh had had uh he uh he just
invited me and sunetto to come to some
little conference where we were just
going to discuss the right with the
right strategy but we already arrived
basically at the strategy the strategy I
should tell you it's the least original
thing I've ever worked on
it's the old it's it's I mean it's the
old pandemic Point like it is it isn't
there's nothing there's nothing really
novel in it we wrote it to tell the
world that there were scientists that
disagreed with the lockdowns
we wanted to shatter the idea that there
was a consensus when there wasn't
actually consent many many scientists I
knew were unhappy with the lockdowns
were afraid to say speak up uh many
people were comfortable lockdowns but
afraid to scientists afraid to speak up
yeah okay well I mean you have people
like Tony fauci who controls you know
tens of billions of dollars of funding
for scientists but and actually not just
the funding
um I I guess it's like Francis Collins
the head of the NIH the reason the
reason is they also control the social
status of scientists yeah you can't run
your you can't run your experiments you
don't get NIH funding actually you don't
get you don't get tenure at Big
universities
um so it's it's it's uh it's it's almost
like career suicide speaking up when
someone like Francis Collins or Tony
fauci says no no you can't uh that we we
have to do this we have to do the
lockdown just as a little bit of a side
point what's amongst scientists is it a
majority of scientists who are talking
to each other but keeping quiet or is it
a minority like yourself are you in a
minority of dissenting voices or or
heterodox thinkers I mean I think if you
asked me in October 2020 I would have
said yes we're in a minority are there a
lot of scientists disagree but weird now
I'm not sure I'm not sure that even in
October 2020 we're in minority
um the evidence for that is that when we
put the Declaration out tens of
thousands of scientists signed on to it
almost a million people assigned it
regular people but also you know like
Nobel prize winning scientists infected
these epidemiologists have signed tens
of thousands of doctors have signed it
um
I mean like but and at risk to their
careers like people who put their names
on the front page some of them lost
their jobs that many of them lost
opportunities for Grants uh you know
collaborations teaching they were
ostracized in their in their communities
um just for signing it just for signing
it right for or having this heterodox
idea in the midst of this pandemic
so what were the other uh how was the
other reception then how do we get from
there to you being uh Shadow banned on
on Twitter
well so four days after we wrote the
Declaration
the um the head of the NIH Francis
Collins wrote an email to Tony fauci you
know the famous Tony facci uh calling me
Sinatra Gupta of Oxford University and
Martin koldorf of Harvard University uh
Fringe epidemiologists friend so that's
this which is kind of funny because like
well for lots of reasons my friends of
mine made cards for me you know it says
you know like I'm gonna have it on my
Epitaph it says free and Japanese
um
the irony is that we were just
proposing an idea that was the strategy
used for you know A Century of
respiratory virus pandemic it was really
the least original idea I've ever had
um and uh and and somehow it's Fringe in
this in the midst of this pandemic
um he called for a devastating takedown
of the premise of the pen of the of the
Declaration
and uh then I started getting calls from
media
while asking me why I want to let the
virus rip why did I want to kill old
people
uh and was just an unfair reading like
we were calling for a conversation about
how best to protect old people we're
calling for a conversation just to
acknowledge the harms that were being
done to children to poor people to
working-class people
um and instead it was this demonization
by the very head of the NIH essentially
someone with tremendous power uh abused
it to try to essentially like the idea
was like you know you like to when he
writes Tony Fox he says we're Fringe
epidemiologists calls for a devastating
takedown Tony fasci then responds with
like a a Wired Magazine article
attacking us slandering us thought she
wrote to himself no he he he I mean I
don't know for certain but he like you
know he starts showing up in a lot of
these articles where he's like
essentially slandering us
accusing us of wanting to let the virus
rip
um I mean uh Colin shows up in articles
in effect calling us Fringe Fringe
figures
um
they're sending a signal to other
scientists to stay silent yeah wouldn't
it you know it'd be terrible what would
happen to your career if you were to
speak up in this with the way these guys
did
um
uh and you know the government officials
so they work uh and what was happening
at this time is that the government the
United States and I think also the UK is
they're desperate to control the
Converse that scientific conversation
about covet online yeah this actually
did happen in the UK and there's an
article written that is spectator by
Isabelle oakshaw she ghost wrote the uh
our health secretary at the time Matt
Hancock's pandemic diary she claims that
as early as January 2020 Hancock was in
contact with Twitter about affecting the
algorithms he contacted former lib Dem
Deputy Prime Minister Nick leg who was
at Facebook apparently agreed and
um when your co-authors were at Downing
Street apparently he threw all his toys
out at the pram but you're absolutely
right we had the same thing over here
so what you have then is government
using its power to control
the speech of private citizens
and that's a that's a direct violation
of the American First Amendment in my
view I mean like you just you it's one
thing for Twitter to decide okay we want
to control the parameters of what speech
is even privately right but that's not
what happened what happened was that
they took instruction from the
government
I'm part of a lawsuit filed by the
Louisiana and Missouri attorney
general's office
against against the Biden Administration
and in that lawsuit we've got to depose
Tony fauci in a number of very high
Administration officials
we also got to read a lot of email
interchanges between these high
officials and social media companies
through the lawsuit through the lawsuit
because they've had to reveal them
they've had to reveal them and what
they've what we found is that there was
direct communication where the
government is telling the social media
companies what to censor in some cases
who to censor like very directly the
government was desperate to control the
conversation to create this illusion
that the the policy they were following
had a scientific consensus behind it
that that's why we had the attack on us
after we wrote the gbd was because the
the effect of the gbd was to shatter the
illusion that there was a consensus
right well just the color in the
atmosphere at the time I think Biden
said I think in summer 2020 or summer
2021 he said social media companies were
killing people because they were
allowing the spread of misinformation
which is actually in contradiction to
what you've said is that censorship is
is what uh kills people I'd like to go
into that but so you discovered that
this was this lawsuit specific to the
gbd or was it to do with the YouTube
super yeah no this was broader broader
than just a gbd so like so we published
a gbd
the Google in many countries actually if
you typed the great brand like we went
we we published it online right so and
then we got like dozens of people
sending us translations of the this one
page document into their language but if
you went in to Google in in uh you know
in some other countries you typed great
branch of Declaration and whatever the
what you'd find is that the search
results were like incredibly biased the
the uh gbd main page was on page three
or whatever of the Google search and all
these hit pieces were above us
um
and uh Facebook we had a little Facebook
page Facebook actually took it down for
a week without telling us giving us any
reason why really
um you know and and uh I mean it was
really clear that social media want
worked to try to suppress knowledge of
the gbd so you've now been into Twitter
Elon Musk invited you in because
uh and a Barry White signaled singles
you out on as an example on her Twitter
files back in December of someone
explicitly uh not shadowband isn't the
the term what's the term it's
blacklisted black Trend blacklisted so
they stopped your tweet from being able
to trend
what did you discover at
the Wow first I I I got to talk with
some of the Twitter Engineers I
discovered that so I joined Twitter in
August of 2021.
um like for various reasons I had never
been on on Twitter before I was like I
figured writing scientific papers is the
way you move people but uh I guess
Twitter is the way you move people
um anyways like I do in trouble too yeah
a little bit um uh so I signed I signed
on uh with with the idea of reaching
people I hadn't reached before right to
tell people what my view of the of covet
science is my view of covert policy is
um
I I got a lot of followers almost
immediately uh for scientists it was it
was you know it's like a a ridiculous
number of followers it seemed to me but
you know but but I'd been in in in
[Music]
um like on on on like some TV shows
before so maybe that's why people have
heard of me
um but what I noticed was that I would
send a tweet and only my followers would
see it I was very rare that I would get
people outside of my you know sort of
the one degree following move me for me
that would see it
um my tweets would never go viral in the
way that uh that that you might be
expected for someone who's like trying
to tweak the I mean I was very careful
on Twitter I didn't I thought I knew
what the bounds of acceptable I
suspected that there was censorship
going on so I knew what the bounds of
acceptable conversation were like
anybody didn't say like the vaccine
causes you to be magnetic or something
silly right
um uh so but but I did say is that these
lockdowns are causing all these harms
and I was linking to Scientific papers
to show that show the harms right I was
advocating for the great parenting
decoration
he didn't reach those uh the the
followers outside of the ones I had
didn't because the trend Blacklist it
turns out was placed on the very day I
joined Twitter
wow total coincidence we don't know like
they just well I mean like why would
Twitter put me on a trans Blacklist I
mean their job
they get they get a benefit from having
a lot of Engagement
I'm generating a lot of Engagement for
them yeah with these but what looked
like controversial ideas or they were
like you know vanilla ideas actually but
whatever seemed controversial at the
time they look vanilla now yeah
um but but so that but then um so I
don't think it was ever in Twitter's
interest to suppress it they were doing
it on the behest of the government like
why would they suppress me on the put me
on a black list on the first day I
joined is this you're thinking of what
you've learned now because that's what I
learned now yeah so they you don't think
you would have been censored had they
been left to the if they hadn't had
government influence yeah I think there
was no government influence they would
have left me I mean you know a stamp
Professor there's there's just no way by
themselves they would have decided that
I was so outside the bounds that I
needed to be put on it's not
inconceivable because there are other
examples where they were acting if you
look at how they took down Trump from
Twitter there wasn't government well I
think they might have been but I think
there was probably there was government
pressure there was government pressure
there but I think that they were
themselves consider themselves activists
and and were are acting not necessarily
with government uh yeah I mean I think
a lot of a lot of you know like a lot of
Silicon Valley is controlled with from
what you know from the left like the
left political views
um but I think even when the left
there's this mix of there's still a a
reverence for free speech like some some
you know I don't think I mean of course
there's some authoritarian left that
wants wants to control speech and thinks
some speech is so dangerous it shouldn't
happen but there's still you know like a
lot of big Tech is founded by people who
have very strong ideological commitments
to free speech and there's still enough
of that left over that I just don't I
it's I find it hard to believe I mean I
could be proven wrong but like I I find
hard to believe that they'd move so far
as to say we want to suppress all speech
right some speech is dangerous you know
like physical threats to people
obviously you want to suppress that that
that's reasonable to suppress
um but like
you know like a scientist talking about
his results or or scientific results on
the central scientific policy question
of the day
I mean I just I find it hard to believe
that they on their own would decide to
suppress that especially since I wasn't
putting conspiracy theories out I was I
was not saying the vaccine uh makes you
magnetic or there's microchips I'm not
saying anything ridiculous I'm just
saying here's the harms of lockdown
cause I actually I did write that the
vaccine doesn't stop disease
transmission
um because when when it became
abundantly clear from the scientific I
think it was like in summer of 2021 when
I started writing about that
um because it was an important topic but
I was reflecting what the scientific
literature was saying did you get in
trouble for that no no I was I was on
the continual Blacklist like me I'd be a
doctor so you go to San Francisco into
the Twitter offices this is post must
take over and
can you talk me through that experience
that was surreal so like it's uh you
know I think he laid off I mean
thousands and thousands of workers but
when he first signed on board
um the headquarters itself is like this
palatial estate it felt like a five-star
hotel or something it's empty like
there's nobody in it there's like all
the there's this huge dining area no
one's in there downtown San Francisco
yeah downtown San Francisco and um
there's a like the I went there on a
Saturday afternoon or Sunday afternoon
and uh there was
a few Engineers like sitting there like
it was it felt like a newsroom or like
like there was just a buzz of like
they're trying to keep the thing going
um Elon Musk is in a in a conference
room huddled with with other Engineers
they're talking about I don't know if
they're talking about some some
engineering thing about how to keep
Twitter running
um and then uh uh he meets with me for
an hour
uh it was it was surreal it was really
interesting because I was really curious
to find out why is he doing this like
you know like I live just south of San
Francisco it's like I'm driving up for
an hour it's about about you know 45
minute drive up and that whole drive I'm
thinking okay it cost 44 billion dollars
for me to come to come to this to do
this little Drive
um so much as why why yeah why is he
doing I think he honestly wants free
speech like he was he's you know for him
um a society that doesn't have free
speech can't science engineering
advances can't Thrive
and uh I mean I mean I think you've used
it as a Civic obligation that's why I
asked him like you know you're you're
doing you're revealing of these kinds of
things I mean I'm not going to sue
sweater because I'm really pleased with
what what this openness and transparency
they have but he's opening himself up to
Twitter 1.0 just did a lot of bad things
they suppress people they shouldn't have
suppress them they leaving them
themselves open to like all the lawsuits
and things and he's like yeah I know
that
um but it's worth it it's worth it for
free speech because he could be sued by
what happened at Twitter because he is
he's now the owner so he's responsible
for what they did right I see
um so
what uh what else did you learn in that
hour about uh well I mean he's he's very
clearly
you know very much against lockdowns
like he and he's I think he's been
against lockdowns from the beginning so
did he know about you from the Great
Barrington declaration never heard of
this before he'd never heard of he's
never heard of the great man talk show
okay I mean I think he sends his third
but like yeah he hadn't heard it at the
time so how did he know to invite you
because Barry Weiss okay so she uh I I
met I've known her for absolutely a
couple years she allowed me to write
stories for her for her um
uh which was thing called The Free Press
now
um which was a fantastic Outlet uh but
but so when when Elon invited her to
come report on the Twitter files
she wanted to find she wanted to write
about prominent scientists that were
that were censored so she searched for
me and and uh my main my name came up as
a Twitter Blacklist she put
that she put me as like one of the the
only scientist that was like in her in
her list that she'd had that was uh that
was censored and so that that's how I
think what Elon Musa learned about me I
see so you did you have any insight
about the machinations of Twitter and
is it Bots that were doing the censoring
was it individuals what Insight did you
get there it's a it's a mix right so I
think the most of the censoring is done
by AI right so like someone sends a list
of words
trigger words or something you know 5G
or something and now now the the AI will
say okay this is something to to to flag
or sensor automatically
um
but there are a a ton of requests from
media companies to to censor you can see
that in the in the in the database that
they have media companies yeah people
people work for media companies like you
know reporters wanting to send things
censored reporters wanting to suppress
speech yeah what what exactly do you
remember as many examples I I mean I
don't want to bring the IFR on me so I'm
not going to like name names but like it
just it was you know it's just it was
like you know
um yeah the these these notes from
saying okay this this crosses the line
this that that crosses the line you
should you should you should suppress
this
um I didn't see anything directly from
governments in my in my time at Twitter
but other people other you know
reporters who've actually gone there and
done this have found notes from
government officials yeah about who to
censor and what to censor oh we know
that now it was it wasn't just the Biden
and inspiration the Trump Administration
as well and and uh the DNC and various
governmental groups absolutely and and
that was revealed by tahibian and Barry
White's in the in the in the Twitter
files
um so what was the story with
YouTube and DeSantis because you were
also censored there am I right yeah so I
still can't I still can't wrap my mind
around this so so um
uh in March of 2021 Governor DeSantis
invited me to a policy Roundtable
and the question one of the questions
there's several questions like one on
whether there should be vaccine mandates
or or or not
um absolutely not
um a bit but but uh one of the questions
that came up is where the governor asked
me directly was is there any evidence
that masking children has any effect on
disease spread
I knew he was going to ask me this
because he'd given me proper you know a
little bit with a list of questions so I
I looked up the literature there are no
randomized studies documenting any
benefit at all to masking children
none still to this day
so that's why I said I said look there's
no there's no scientific there's no high
quality scientific evidence suggesting
that that we do then at the time all
these like in the United States
especially there was a craze of masking
children's young is two years old
um you know toddlers
um and uh and I I was just reflecting
what the scientific evidence was saying
right and and it's a sitting governor of
a state asking a science science
advisors
the scientific basis for policy
decisions he's about to make
YouTube so there was a there was a uh uh
TV
channel that was like filming this event
I mean it wasn't all that exciting it's
just scientists talking to a governor
right but but on the other hand it's
like it's kind of a good government
thing
you can see what your Governor I'm from
California it was my government but his
but people afford could see what the
governor what advice the governor was
getting directly it's actually that's
exactly what we want to see absolutely
as far as transparency in government
um they put this TV uh this TV station
put the the video on YouTube
through the next day then they censored
it they cut they dropped this video
YouTube with a TV channel YouTube
wow censored it um because of what I
said
because I said that there's no benefit
there's no scientific evidence that
masking children has any benefit
wow
um I mean it's just it's mind-blowing
like the and and I I don't know directly
it was at the request of the government
um but it might have been like you know
that we might have tripped a keyword or
or something but you just you can't have
that you can't have a you can't actually
have uh this uh a communication uh sort
of medium that's aimed at public
furthering public discourse that censors
the functionings of government
transparency like transparent government
even if you disagreed with me although I
you'd have to then disagree with
scientific literature but whatever even
if you disagreed with me you should get
to hear what I've been saying to the
governor right yeah I mean this all the
more shocking that this is a country
where freedom speech is
in the Bill of Rights yeah you'd have
thought of in America of all places that
this this couldn't happen now I I want
to go into the the the greater
implications of what censorship as a
I've heard you say censorship kills but
before doing that I think I want to
understand what happened at Stanford
University and you describe being uh
intimidated and uh silenced uh there
um in a recent tablet magazine uh
article would you mind um
that was really painful right Winston it
was really hard to write um so
Stanford's my home like I've been at
Stanford for 36 years
if you asked me three years ago is there
any problem with with
um academic freedom I would have told
you absolutely not like I I've given
dozens of dozens and dozens of of
seminars uh sometimes with very
controversial ideas it's I mean you know
it's it's science right you're gonna say
things that people disagree with you
just you resolve it by thinking of
experiments or find getting new data
it's fine to disagree in science right
um during the pandemic Stanford has did
not organize a single seminar where
people who uh that were opposed to the
lockdowns and they were very prominent
people at Stanford opposed lockdowns
like people like Johnny unities the most
the most high you know one of the most
highly cited scientists in the world
uh a Nobel Prize winner Mike Levitt
Scott Atlas who was the uh advisor
president Trump on coveted policy
that's a very prominent
people who oppose the lockdowns
none of us were invited to give a
seminar
on campus
talking about our views the the
leadership never organized a debate
between us and people who disagreed with
us on campus they could have
um and what happened on campus was that
that essentially uh the views especially
Scott when he went to go advise Trump
now all of a sudden Scott was the was
the you know devil incarnate right just
for the sin of advising a president on
on Covert policy
um and on campus those the views were
seen as like so far outside the bounds
you couldn't even bring them up right
that's why that's why they didn't invite
us for seminar uh after I advised uh
Governor DeSantis in that video you know
with that video that got taken down
about about
um a couple months after that there was
a big wave of cases in Florida every
place on Earth has experienced ways with
cases it's just unfortunately that's the
way the nature of this disease
um there was a poster campaign where
there was a picture of me
next to the deaf you know the the number
of deaths in Florida essentially
accusing me of killing people in Florida
and they put it on kiosks all over
campus including a coffee shop that on
campus that that I'm known to go to
um reminded what you said was that
mosques didn't prevent the spread of
infectious of covid amongst children and
they made the the jump then to assume
that you were somehow responsible for
the jump in cases in Florida Florida
yeah um so that's pretty intimidating
those posts those flies are sort of
around campus
yeah at the time like for almost for two
years from 2020 to 2021 I was getting
death threats constantly and I was
getting
just random people whenever I appear on
TV I get a death I get death threats
racist attacks it was it was just now I
mean it was just part of the background
noise I mostly ignored it but then when
the posters came up
um on campus a friend of mine sent me a
picture of it right next to the coffee
house I would go to it was like it felt
personal like somebody was directly
attacking me in the place in my home
and I felt physically afraid to go on
campus for a couple of days after after
a couple days I'm like okay whatever
happens happens I'm just gonna go
um I I called up the department chair I
told him like this I don't I don't feel
safe going on campus what can you do you
you sent me to some advisor who told me
to uh reduce my online presence you know
I'm like in the middle of this massive
sign off worldwide scientific War
I'm not going to reduce my online
presence I mean just it's part of the I
mean it's just part of like I have to
communicate with the public I be quiet
yeah that's the that's what you need to
do yeah sorry go on I mean that's
exactly how I read it
um so it just felt like I was
like first by not organizing seminars
they essentially delegitimized my view
on campus they created an atmosphere
with this kind of demonization within
many other seminars going on yeah there
were those other semins lots of jobs on
Zoom but yeah they're wrong right okay
um you know there were uh there's
something called Grand rounds in the
medical school once a week you get one
very prominent person get who's invited
to report on their research or some
ideas that they have to the whole of the
medical school right that you know over
the pandemic there have been you know
150 some Grand rounds and you'd have
thought seeing as they have the one of
the co-authors of the Great Barrington
declaration Johnny and ladies I mean
they could they should have invited one
of us not one mm-hmm
so so then uh you you'll your voice is
being silenced then although you're not
actually having anything apart from sort
of being told to be quiet is the best
way to deal with the Flies were there
any other ways in which you were sort of
silenced at Stanford it was I mean like
during that that Santa Clara study there
was a there was a um that that there was
a allegation that uh so what happened
was like the the study was funded by a
very large number of like Anonymous
donors or or small dollar donors the way
that normally works I mean I'd never
gotten all my funding before that had
come from the National Institute of
Health I didn't have never experienced
this kind of thing but like we announced
that we were doing the study a lot of
people wanted the study to happen and so
they gave a little bit of money to
Stanford so the JetBlue founder
you know for this Airline founder gave
five thousand dollars to Stanford for
the study
there was a buzzfeed article claiming
that somehow that money had had
influenced my my reporting or that bias
the study was I have no idea how why
what direction or what it just makes no
sense for five thousand dollars I mean I
didn't even see the money went to
Stanford
but Stanford opened an investigation of
me
uh but they very quickly turned it into
like a fact-finding thing they found
nothing wrong because I'm dying let's
say it's just just it's tremendously
stressful I started getting like friends
of mine pre I guess former friends of
mine
um started telling me like you know that
they're gonna defriend me on Facebook it
was that was this most silly challenge
the petty
um and then but then and then like I
heard there were a hund like that
someone was circulating a petition
uh and the chair of epidemiology
circulated uh helped circulate the
petition it didn't quote me directly but
it quoted what I said during that
DeSantis interview
um
saying that there's no high quality
evidence right
um for for child masking and and it said
this is a dangerous opinion to ask the
president University to censor people
who have this opinion make clear this is
um I mean at that point I mean at a
hundred of my of friends signed it
wow you know some of them I didn't know
but some of my friends signed the thing
I mean wow I have to be forgiving you
know once I just I mean I'm happy to
forgive them
um but uh it's hard to like well you
know it's just it was painful right it
was just it was like it felt the sense
of like I'm being excommunicated from
the from the uh from the University you
know I've been there for 36 years I've
been teaching for 20 years I've written
papers with some of these folks
um it was just it was it was just it was
painful
I can only imagine so zooming out then
um to this idea that uh you know as a
quoted Biden earlier he was saying that
social media companies were were killing
people by not spreading uh by not
stopping the spread of misinformation
and you've said that actually censorship
kills for anyone who who believes that
censorship was the right thing to do
in that scenario what is your argument
and and do you think that you can say
you can back that up
scientifically uh after covid that
actually censorship does kill I mean I
think the key thing is um
I mean it's hard to answer it's hard to
like just to like make a counterfactual
and be entirely persuasive you have to
like think what the world might have
been like without it but I I I don't
think there's I don't think if you think
about it there's a lot of controversy
about this like so so the uh let's take
the argument in its face about why
censorship would be good right so some
ideas spread that are incorrect
and sometimes people act on those ideas
in ways that lead to harm to them and
maybe to others
right so
um
like take some of the worst of these
ideas right so like you know uh the the
the uh
early ideas about like uh you know I
don't know like the the
something president Trump said about you
know uh I don't think he exactly said
this but like uh some people
misinterpret like interpreters like
saying bleach would kill the thing and
like maybe maybe they drink bleach right
that that's a that's a harm of not
censoring that idea right he didn't
quite say that but yes yes like someone
could misinterpret it that way right
yeah right
um that would be a harm of it I I if
like if you're if you're honest you say
Okay I accept that that might be a harm
but the counter argument is that uh if
you have a trustworthy public health
authority that says no no don't drink
bleach
why you have to say that you're like
you're thinking human beings I have no
idea but like anyways like that that you
say that right
and people believe it because the public
health authority is saying is is
trustworthy right the vaccines doesn't
make you magnetic there's not there's no
5G chips in it right a trustworthy
public health authority says that and
people believe it and so you can counter
the misinformation with trustworthy
information from trustworthy sources
um
with censorship what happens is that it
breathes distrust in the authorities
that are censoring
so
when the authorities get something
really substantively wrong like so for
instance the authority said things like
if you are vaccinated you will not get
the disease and you will not spread the
disease
well people saw from their own personal
experience that wasn't true yeah right I
got the vaccine two doses and then four
months later I got coveted
I I'm not the only one I mean
so
now all of a sudden
the the entities that are doing the
censoring
are no longer trustworthy and now all
the all of the all of these like
not so smart ideas they're not gone
they're just gone Underground
and no one trusts the authorities to to
counter them
um and then there's another another
another argument which is that um when
you have censorship and and the the
authorities get it wrong
it takes longer to counter them yes
right so we've essentially created with
these vaccine mandates a two-class
society like undermine trust in vaccines
what if they had allowed voices to very
early on to say Lord look this vaccine
doesn't stop transmission didn't censor
that idea
fact right or that if you've had coven
recovered you actually have fairly good
protection against covet against
reinfection and and certainly against
severe disease on reinfection
so those are facts that the public
health authority essentially denied
I'd have thought that you might have
linked this back to the Great Barrington
declaration because
if you're you you're sort of arguing the
damage that lockdowns would
lockdowns did and that that might suit
your argument I mean I I absolutely
think that that we would have won that
argument
much earlier had there not been
censorship right so I still talk to
people who don't have never heard of the
Great Barrington declaration didn't
still don't know that there was a
scientific Insurgency I guess against
the lockdown idea so I agree with you
when it's absolutely right that I think
that uh we lost that that argument we
lost the policy argument in October 2020
through foul means do you feel that now
looking back two years on that you
do you still believe you were correct uh
do you is there any sort of evidence
that you can you can profit to suggest
that you were correct yeah I mean so
first the the fact of lockdown homes I
mean everyone everyone's experienced
them right so you know like in July of
2020 the CDC did a study that one in
four Young Americans had seriously
considered suicide
right so the the anxiety and depression
that comes from what's the normal right
like three four percent
wow okay so that's a huge Choice it was
an enormous jump right so like
um and that you know like that the the
the the kind of like we you know we're
social creatures we need we need company
we need to be in physical presence of
others
um you know no matter how misanthropic
you are you need that
yeah I mean even like this you know
introverted scientists like me will will
need we'll need to like talk to people
right so it's just that's just the way
it goes
um uh so everyone's felt that that harm
that lockdown home probably directly uh
the the idea of like schooling well kids
have a lot who were forced out of school
mainly poor kids for for very extended
peace time they have tremendous learning
loss
measured right uh We've created this
generational inequality that didn't
exist that existed before but it's
exacerbated through through this through
these lockdown measures on kids
um in poor countries
and Uganda for instance four and a half
million kids never came back to school
after two years of closed School wow A
Lost Generation many of them like little
girls
were sold into sexual slavery because
their parents couldn't afford to feed
them
they would often get food from the
school
um the lockdown harms are you know like
the economic males we're going through
now it's directly related to the
economic policies we adopted the
spending the printing of money all of
that
the devastation of small businesses that
happen during the lockdowns as a result
of the lockdowns right so I don't think
I think the fact that those lockdown
harms are undeniable right I think
everyone everyone agrees that was that
was one of the main planks of the great
branch of Declaration right
um the idea that lockdowns wouldn't
protect people
on near I mean what fraction of the
mayor of the American population or the
UK population has had covered like
nearly everybody has had coveted
wow what did the lockdowns actually
accomplish other than maybe delay
um
uh and uh and in terms of like did they
protect against
deaths from covid but you can look at
the counter example of Sweden Sweden
didn't lock down they had voluntary
measures they had guidance for you know
they told people they reasonably people
like adults and said look here's who's
high risk you know you might want to be
careful when the disease is spreading
don't go out so much deliver food to
your neighbor if they're older so I mean
things like that like they create a
community that was responding to try to
like work together rather than these
like you know these mandates and
um force uh and they they're all cause
Exodus deaths are lower than basically
almost every other country in Europe
like maybe other than Norway
um do you have a sense of Injustice
about what happened that this censorship
of the of your work
considering how it's how it played out I
mean I I had a sense of sadness okay
it's not so much me I mean like I just I
feel
I I feel like the scientific Community
let let regular people down right we
didn't allow our normal processes to
play through we would have won that
argument Winston if we if it had been if
if the normal scientific processes we
would have won the anti-lockdown
argument we would have won the focus
protection argument
um and instead you had scientific
bureaucrats abusing their position
for hubris I mean they thought they were
right and they weren't
um and so the the um and and the people
who paid the price I mean I I mean I for
me it's like it's okay yeah I paid some
price with my you know I lost a bunch of
friends but like I also made a
tremendous number of friends in contact
like it's just in many ways
scientifically it's been the most
exhilarating time of my career
um but the kids that lost their
opportunities for for schooling the
people who lost their their small
businesses that their life savings
um the the the young adults who who are
like deeply depressed and isolated uh
the the men and women who have late
stage cancer now that should have been
picked up early all these people that
were damaged by these policies I mean I
felt I feel some sense of responsibility
over this
because we should have we should have
spoken for I mean we tried to speak for
them and we did they weren't heard yeah
uh now uh looking looking back and the
world has moved on but I wonder as an
epidemiologist whether you could uh I'd
love to know your opinion on a couple of
things that have now come up in the news
for example the cdcr exploring a link
between a fisa booster and uh Strokes in
uh Elder people and
um and Britain as well there's a report
of 30 000 excess deaths in the time
March 2020 to August 2022 now we don't
know whether that's because of the
vaccines because of covert itself
because of
NHS problems and and ambulance shortages
and uh but I wondered if you had an
opinion as uh the efficacy of of
vaccinations and any damage they might
be uh you know uh I think it's I think
it's likely that the for older people
because they have such a high rate of
death I think the vaccines do reduce the
rate of death from covid and so for
older people it's likely that they save
lives they're almost certain that they
save lives
um for younger people it's a much closer
question I mean it may not have
um I don't I think for young men it's
pretty well established that the vaccine
especially the MRNA vaccines cause you
know myocarditis
which can kill you like it's not it's
not something you don't want you you
don't necessarily want if you can avoid
it
um the race is there evidence of that
there's absolutely evidence of that so
like I think it's something on the order
of one in three thousand one in two
thousand we could it's you know like you
could convince me it's lower than that
but not not much lower
um
so uh but what that means is that for
young men the risk benefit calculation
is like much closer to why do it
um
I don't believe that the vaccines have
killed the very large number of people I
I just I I just the evidence that I've
looked at doesn't
coincide with that but I do think that
the vaccine should have just been
targeted older people that's whom it
benefited the most for younger people
maybe the recommendation should have
been go talk to your doctor if you have
high risk conditions that make make it
so that if you get covered it'll be bad
for you then get the vaccines otherwise
maybe not
but if if to describe the scientific
Community as being so sort of captured
within an ideology was do you have any
sense that doc doctors might have been
the same medicine might be the same or
is was there sort of more sensibility or
more sense rather in in in that world no
there was there was tremendous pressure
on doctors to toe the line on the
vaccines more pressure than I've ever
seen put on the medical profession
professionals to to say exactly what
public health wanted them to say
um so that that would have been
difficult it would have required a
different Public Health response it
would require Public Health response
where doctors were treated as partners
rather than subjects
um so what you have what you what you
what you needed was a nuanced response
that took into account patients actual
actual condition like each every person
is different from each other what might
be right for you to take may be wrong
for me to take vice versa you're a young
man is probably much less important for
you to have taken the vaccine than it
was for me to take it
um and for when my 80 year old mom much
more important for her to take it
um
so I think that that kind of IDEA Public
Health could have just said that instead
it was there was this pressure that
everyone had to be vaccinated with the
false premise that if everyone's
vaccinated the disease will go away
well the vaccine doesn't stop you from
getting disease means it can't stop you
can't get rid of the disease with it
therefore it's not so important that
literally everyone is vaccinated in
terms of like the herd immunity idea
um that I mean that public health just
made a mistake there like an enormous
mistake and it took him for us they
still have to corrected it um
thinking more sort of positively for the
future now I have things calmed at
Stanford and uh do you feel that now
that we're past covet somewhat that you
are Freer now with your at what you're
able to say and
given also that we've got this
revolution happening at Twitter and
perhaps in Tech you're online you'll be
you'll be Freer or is there still a sort
of Legacy from that period where there
are circumstances where you cannot speak
freely uh Mia Stanford
um
there still hasn't been an
acknowledgment that that by the
leadership that that they essentially
violated the mission of the place the
mission of the place is is you know the
motto is like left the Winds of Freedom
blow um
I think wins the freedom didn't blow the
first three years I I do think it's
opening up some I still haven't been
invited to give us a seminar uh with uh
my uh like people who were in favor of
the lockdowns like they still have not
organize that kind of seminars yet
um but there was a conference on
academic freedom at Stanford where I got
to tell my my story
it's starting to thaw
um but there needs to be some
acknowledgment by current leadership I
actually think they need to be changing
leadership uh to to a set of people who
are leaders who actually actually are
committed to the mission of the
University which is to
free expression of ideas in pursuit of
knowledge how could there even be
pursuit of knowledge like how can you do
your experiment experimentation if you
not able to talk about it
it's ridiculous I think a lot of a lot
of people at Stanford just want to move
on pretend like the last three years
didn't happen
um I don't think that's healthy I think
that we need to do it an honest
conversation about we hadn't had an
honest conversation about what happened
and make sure it never happens again
like we have to recommit to our I mean
this is I mean this is Stanford we're
talking about Stanford because I'm it's
my home but like but I think it's just
it's a broader conversation for our
Western democracies yeah and the
universities the University's particular
audit of what happened yeah over the
last three years yeah
um uh like for me personally 2022 and
2023 the the death threat stopped
um the it looked it moved a lot more
like the policy moved in the in the
direction of the Great Barrington
declaration like in yeah in the UK you
have what like Freedom Day and in like
uh July August or 2021 or something yeah
I'm not sure how many people celebrating
that but yeah
I mean the point is that like that that
that the the the idea that we have to
suppress the virus at all costs that
essentially is dead now in most places
even China has gotten rid of that idea
right
um and happened rather more violently
over there yeah well I mean they they
they went for this crazy zero profit
idea it was hopeless and at Great cost
of their society for what this is a
virus that you really can't eventually
is going to spread everywhere
if you can if you're going to devote
resources to protecting it you should
just devote it to protecting the most
vulnerable people and once we have the
vaccine
I mean that's easy right what you do is
use the VA you vaccinate older people at
high risk
the Freedom Day at policy actually made
actually quite a bit of sense like the
idea was like okay UK had vaccinated its
older population
lift the lockdowns because the older
population is not protected by the end
of the vaccines the U.S we just I mean
the blue States we kept going I'm not
entirely sure that's what happened in
the UK and this our reference back to
the article by um
shot about Hancock because she describes
him as having made so many orders of
vaccines that once he had uh
finished with the Elder people he then
wanted went on a mission to vaccine
everyone else and so perhaps he kind of
got went on ideological yeah
routing or something but uh yeah I mean
you're right I mean there was there was
there was there was there was the
pressure in the US was even more right
so like vaccinated kids as young as like
six months old
um why I don't know I'm like I really
don't really need it
um you know six month olds don't really
die at very high rates like Vanishing a
few six-month-olds died of covet
um
so I I don't I don't know I I mean I I I
I don't know the motive exactly but I
will say it was epidemiological was the
wrong thing to do like there was no
reason to pressure young people to get
vaccinated and the idea was like if I if
you don't get vaccinated you're gonna
put me in danger well that was that was
that was not true
right if you'd had covert before and
recovered actually you were better
protected against getting disease and
spreading it then it's a vaccinated
individual never had code before
the vaccine then also doesn't stop you
from getting covered
we created this two-class Society for
nothing Public Health did that and and
the pressure to vaccinate was tremendous
right I mean you're absolutely right to
correct me like the Hancock bed
definitely did that I mean in the UK
um but it eased up faster than in
California for instance there's still
like they're still like in New York
state a couple of days ago the governor
of New York was asked well why are why
don't you hire back the nurses that you
fired
during the pandemic who were
unvaccinated you're sure there's a
shortage of nurses in in hospitals why
not bring them back
and she still said
two days ago a couple days like or
yesterday that uh that the VAC that
these nurses put their patients at risk
like we we created an underclass of
unvaccinated people
wow and you should answer that still
exists I think I think it still exists
to some extent to you I mean it's
starting to lift but it's but um it's
it's still The Echoes of that are going
to go on for a long time there are a lot
of people who no longer trust any
vaccines
because they feel discriminated against
on but by public health who got the
facts about this vaccine wrong yeah how
do you do you still trust them do you
how have you do I trust Public Health
yeah I'm a scientist I'm supposed to be
skeptical
um
I think Public Health I mean it is the
Norms are different right so like public
health is uh it's not just doing science
they're also like communicating science
and the Practical applications of the
science of the population at large so
there is an element of trust and faith
that they have to have
my view is that the best way to Garner
that trust and maintain it is by telling
the truth 100 of the time even when it's
inconvenient
when you get it wrong transparently
admitting that you got it wrong treating
the population like adults
um
that's not what public health the public
health Embrace this idea of a noble lie
right if I I lie to you about the
efficacy of mass
why because otherwise you won't wear
them I'll lie to you about whether the
vaccine stopped transmission or whether
if you're covered recovered if you have
any immunity why because you might then
otherwise not get the vaccine yeah those
lies undermine trust yeah a reasonably
undermined trust and if you think you're
fighting some great evil the noble lies
is always Justified yeah until until
like No One Believes you yeah which is I
I mean it's not No One Believes Public
Health but large fraction populations
like
who are these people why do they think
they know what know it all when they've
been wrong so many times
well a world in which we tell the truth
100 of the time I think is one I uh hope
will come into peace
okay fine like in our own pop it's like
it's hard to like but but like but for
for public health like professionally
exactly yeah yeah exactly just no I
wasn't actually joking yeah I think
you're I mean you're right I mean that's
that is that is exactly the right Norm
and we just we just utterly failed at
that I'll still tell my kids when well
my grandkids when I eventually have them
that Santa Claus exists
[Music]
well on that note Dr Jay battacharya
thank you very much for your time I'm
sure listeners and Watchers would have
found that fascinating thank you too
[Music]